all right miss rita
how are you darling i'm doing just great
it's so nice to hear so so you and i
have known each other for
a long time now right a year and a half
yes sir and
your life has changed a lot a whole lot
and i'm very thankful
for the blessings that god blessed me
today you're one of the
people that i'm able to help with like
rent and you know i give you money for
food and clothes and
little things like that and
i think i think it helps it helps a lot
what helps you
very appreciate it you were getting
treated very badly
yes like ready to really go to the back
to the mental world
it's like i was gonna go through a
relapse
right and i was running in front of cars
until i met you
trying to hurt myself until i met you
i'm happy
and i thank the people's very much
kindly
for reaching out to me to have a place
to live
and it's satisfying for me as well to to
be able to help somebody who
who really needed it because you were in
a situation where i met you that was
yes sir unless i've heard and to say
thank you also for giving me the
opportunity
to come to your filming as well
as my life i'm more happy or peaceful
and i feel like i'm somebody
everybody a lot of stuff buddy yeah
you're happier now for sure
good to see you smile more and i'm
pretty yes you are pretty
thanks to the donations and mark
i stay clean now i'm not prostituting
around i'm not
have to beg nobody you you had a rough
life there you when i first met you you
were working as
you were turning tricks on the street
you were you you
you were being like denied feeding some
of the feedings i
had germs thing also i am very thankful
i'm
okay i'm clean yeah yeah i just got
asked
and i think most importantly maybe
you're happy i
am thank you yes and people's now
uh socialize with me and communicate
they're not saying i'm nasty and turned
down they hugs me in a building you have
some friends where you stay
am i no i just stay to myself but
they hug me say good morning they treat
me a lot different and better not like i
feel better
how important is is having like respect
in your life it's very important because
you were depressed
yeah it's depressing like i'm not wanted
it's almost like
you're being treated like an animal yeah
and i was getting to the point where
they'd say get out the streets though
i'd say i don't care if nobody liked me
but now i'm very happy stay clean the
most important thing i'm
and i can eat what i want yeah and
you're dressed well
yeah thank you thanks to y'all donations
and mark
yes i like your clothes nice clothes
you're very stylish always yeah and
so so you've been on skid row for how
many years
since i came to california and which
when was that
98 98 i used to sleep
in a bus a bad day bus
but i my house is beautiful too they
fixed the last little hole from the rat
thanks to
mark and y'all donations
i had a big hole under my sink and the
stove and they fixed
yeah you're one of the sro hotels here
yeah in
skid row yes but it's but i feel real
beautiful at night and i'mma work on
doing something
more positive in my life so i could get
a magnet of my mom to put in my room
oh that's nice yeah when i turned 60
though
how do you know i'm 58. you're 58 yeah
i just turned 15 january but i wanted
magnus of my mom because she taught you
she your height
but she looked just like me and my
daughter looked just like her too
so and you have a daughter where's your
daughter in washington dc
and i would like to ask if there's any
way of
any of y'all in my family shirley walden
last hurt was in sacramento or my
daughter's astronautist
and secretary for washington y'all could
contact me
or if it's any way that y'all look at
the soft white underbelly
because i would like to start getting to
know you guys and be part of the family
this is your sister yes sir and that's
my daughter
in washington who you've lost contact
with i never
said like 10 years i used to be a wine
garden still
when i went to a drug program but i'm
ready
i'm doing better in my life and i want
to get to know you guys because
i never knew you guys because my mother
never left me
she always dropped them off you were
very close to your mom yes
i never had a chance to know my sister
because she'd get drunk
she'll drop them off at my aunt but she
never
leave me nowhere what was your childhood
like
i stayed up under my mom drinking and
stuff
your mom was drinking yeah she was a
real alcoholic
and not underground folks my
friends from school want to come home
with me i don't want to play with them i
want to be with grown folks
with my mom you like to be you want to
be with your mom yeah
so i still want to be with my mom i'd be
at the front door i'm waiting for her
because i
read my word three times or even more
just feel like i'm bored i'll go in the
room and read and
god told me she's coming back
and i wait cause that's how she died she
fell up
in front of the door throwing up blood
and said serotonin
in the front door where i stayed that
was that right so i believe she's coming
back on this earth
she reincarnated
the more i get closer to her what was
your favorite memory
my favorite memory is my mother's
getting drunk
and out they her men friends and stuff
throw me quarters instead of giving me
candy to roll my stomach and
shake my butt and sing that's it
that's why i said i'll be madly cold too
i sing all in the building now i got
everybody playing i'm catching their
natalie cole you're you're a performer
you think of me yeah
you like to sing and dance yes i do
yeah and everybody want to hear me sing
that too so now they really liking me a
lot
thanks to you they're starting to like
me self-respect is
an important thing for everybody yeah it
do
they don't feel bad but i i would like
any of my family to contact you like i
said
soft white underwear yeah you just leave
a comment under the video and
we'll we'll make some connections
somewhere yeah because there's an email
at the top of that because i'm sure
my nieces now probably look at this
all the time on my daughter and yeah i
have some part of the family but
my life's been fine real good and i've
been real happy
not want for nothing you're fine with
you're fine where you're at you don't
need you don't need a castle you don't
need anything
no i'm just thankful to be normal
but i'm real happy because i'm able to
be clean and pre
have nice clothes and be able to eat i
ain't got to
ask nobody for nothing that's happy to
have helped you out
people like you and jerry and and i
really mean it i am happy just for a
meal and looking like i am yeah there's
there's been a couple people beautiful
there's another one i think
when drugs are not a big part of the
picture it becomes so much easier
for me to help people yeah and i know
you have a
history of drugs but yeah but the people
in the bill didn't even say uh yeah
i look nice there's a lot of crazy stuff
going on you're building yeah you're in
the same building with lewis right
yeah yeah and now so i'm getting a lot
of attention since
the people's donut been donating and
helping me out and you
uh they not a lot of attention but they
like me now
that's great yeah they like me they
don't think i'm germs
or nothing no more yeah no you're not
you're good
you're lovely reading thank you so much
you're welcome very welcome
now that i'm gonna work on really being
good if i could do some
instead of getting stuff for nothing and
not prostituting
probably the lord's work or so to get a
magnet
of my mom before i die we're happy with
that yeah
that's easy when i get 60.
i don't care if i got to make it myself
get some clayton
but i'm drawing her right now but i got
pictures but yeah
that's i'm happy very happy now and
thankful all right thank you very much
you very welcome and the people who
reach out and donate to me god bless
y'all and thank you and mark
very much
you